every [__] day is a mind [__] we got
a year left
if the mayans are right we got a year
left go home tonight [__] mama
and [__] her every night i don't care if
she doesn't wear because mama you guys
like to have a good time
no we had a great time at the show oh am
i tired
tired you were just giggling and having
a good time what happened
let's take this party to the house let's
get the handcuffs and [__]
[Applause]
and women have two different outfits on
they got the [__] suit and then i'm not
even [__] suit
the [__] suit is the football shirt half
ripped with
the freckles the nipple comes out and
the thong
that's like i might [__] you if you play
your cards right
then there's the you're in no danger
that's the grandma panties with the
pajama bottoms
with the t-shirt with the pajama top
button to the [__] top like
like she's going to a [__] party or
something with peter pan
then they got a blanket and a blanket on
top of that and a blanket on top of that
a blanket on top of that
and a loose blanket on top of that and a
cat on top of that you know what i'm
saying
[__] houdini can't get to that [__]
with a pocket of [__]
tuna
and then god forbid you try to wake him
up in the middle of night you ever try
giving mama a stabbing in the middle of
night you try to
because that's the best time to give him
a stabbing because there's no talking
you know what i'm saying it's quick
as a matter of fact you want to go back
to bed go ahead i'll finish it so low
you understand me
take a minute i'll i'll come on my own
stomach you ever get to that point
i'll come on my own stomach don't trip i
ain't gonna come in the middle
that's for the cat i ain't gonna move
him right now
[Applause]
you ever get like that in the middle you
just wake them up with your dick because
it's like
it's like sign language you just tap
them with the helmet and they swat it
like it's a fly like what are you
like [__] i've been doing push-ups
lately i've been working on this helmet
then you got to rub the pre-come on
their leg you rub the pre-come on that
way
that really gets them they wake right
the [__] up
[Applause]
what is that on my leg you know what's
on your [__] leg
it's going to be on your neck if you
don't roll over in a second
i swear to god you'll stick to the
[__] pillow tonight
right like a bag of peanuts that's that
sticky [__] you know what i'm saying
[__] hilarious and it's you that
caused this [__] women just open your
leg like a cat no you start chitter
chattering and talking
the reasons why you can't do it we could
have been done already
done there's no foreplay at two in the
morning a little chinese finger torch
and i stick it right in like a
like a soldier you know what i'm saying
like like a marine shave and dry
[__] it work it out
and we do we try because let me tell you
something what's funny is that
listen i'm the worst [__] piece of
ass there is and i've known this from
day one
i'm not gonna sit here you know those
guys i'm about not like let's stop
stop i've been bad since they [__]
won i just couldn't break the you know
what i'm saying
like i like the sexual crazy [__] i
don't like to just pump until
whatever to get sweaty that's not for me
that's too much harder softer
enough let's work something out where
everybody's [__] happy you know what
i'm saying like
let's figure this because you can't like
i i'm 48 i just learned how to [__] like
three years ago
you really don't know when you're dirty
you think you're good you don't know
[__]
and i bet when i'm 50 i'm even gonna be
better [__] banging it from the sides
cutting [__] toenails while i'm
[__] you know i'm saying
because you got like this indian [__]
karma or something as you get older
first you
but you really don't know and then women
put you down like they don't tell us
because women are the sweetest animals
in the world that
don't have a few [__] filthy animals
that say you suck in bed
but a woman will take it like she'll
take a bad piece of ass if you're a nice
guy
i thought what am i gonna do
he's got a little dick but you know he's
you know so you got like me i like to
eat [__] i just liked it you know some
people have a flavor for [__]
remy martin you know i liked eating that
[__] monkey a lot of people
but it wasn't always like that like we
all start somewhere even women they hate
sucking dick when they're 18.
they suck it with that you know what i'm
saying like they hold it weird they
don't
they don't really grip it like they hold
it like it's on fire
like my dick don't have ben gay on it
grab that [__] you know what i'm
saying like
but we suck the same i mean half you
women like [__]
i wish i'd go back and suck the
quarterback's dick now
he'd really marry me he wouldn't have
married mary jane whatever she was a pig
you know what i'm saying
because you didn't know how to [__]
suck you didn't have the whole acting
the whole you know what i'm saying
and we are not either we don't know what
the [__] we're doing i'm not going to
sit here and tell you i'm telling you
it's [__] hard
and when you know you suck in bed it's
uncomfortable but
it really is because you're like i suck
i just want to get this over with
huh huh all right we're there you know
what i'm saying that and then you change
the subject
wow [__] the lakers are coming back
21 days you know
what is that you don't know you don't
know when you're 16 you're thrown into
this
because it's like i thought i want to
get a [__] at six i didn't want i got
a [__] [__] no nothing
but what popeye talks about a [__]
it's the kids around you that put peer
pressure on you
you know that's a lot of women don't
understand that's why i don't like come
because you don't know what we [__]
went through
you don't know what the [__] we went
through to get come to come out of that
little pee hole
because we forgot about that's how bad
of a [__] experience it is for men
to try to get that gap going you know
that gap when you're walking around like
bozo for a year because
you got like hair on this side of your
dick and hair on this side
but the top is bald you know what i'm
saying you gotta you gotta take a shower
with [__] shorts on with your cousins
and [__]
and they were all [__] loose girl you
know you forget about this [__] guys
this is
this is traumatized this is why we take
it seriously when they
don't you know when they just come on
their tits and they just wipe it off
like
in our hearts we're like oh what the
[__] was she thinking i suffered for
that
people [__] when your kid cousins
come up to you like did you come here
and you're like i'm here
i'm at the party i brought my g.i joe
and they're like no stupid did you
[__] come yet
and it's traumatizing the first time you
know that something comes out of there
and ain't coming out of your dick
you know because there's a woman you
guys grow hair and you get those funnel
titties you get the bra so you trick us
but there's no tricking with hair you
don't know whether we got here even when
we got a little like three hairs
remember guys you get like you
you get like your cousins mascara and
[__] fill in your mustache look at my
stash and [__] you know what i'm saying
but you had nothing
i even put stash like down here like i
was like [__] it up
i put some maybelline mascara on my
the waterproof you know what i'm saying
to really get that [__]
that's the [__] we go to that you never
even think about because it's so [__]
painful
it's so painful to want to be a [__]
man to want to [__] remember the
first year you started whacking off and
nothing would come out
but you get that tickle at the end like
remember that this voice comes out of no
here
what was that and nothing comes out
you're looking around the room you're
like where'd it go
and for a year you just giggle your knee
goes out from under you right
you start doing squats and [__]
but your legs still go it's like you got
[__] hit you're like you're whacking
off watching a playboy
you're like what the and you wake up
against the wall pale and [__]
and you eat wonder bread and milkshakes
and [__] you're like [__] it
because years ago wonder bread had a
commercial the more bread you ate you
grew
right in front of the mirror so i'm
there [__] with my dick eating wonder
bread
rubbing it [__] come on grow
[__] grow
and then comes the day you're like [__]
it i just turned 13 and three quarters
i could feel it
it's coming today and you're like [__]
it i'm going to do it before school
because that's that's a trick you're
like [__]
because you try to do it different times
of the day you're like maybe i'll catch
my nut sack off guard
and something will come out just to set
you free you just want to come
you don't want to get nobody pregnant
you don't want to do nothing you just
want to come and see it and that that's
it that now you
got different walk to you now you know
what i'm saying
where's your sister i don't know i'm not
a [__] babysitter [__]
i'm a man i'm 14 now things are
different you know what i'm saying
that's all you want to do when you're a
little [__] kid that gap that gap
but it throws you off all the days you
think you're gonna come because you
lifted and you ate clams and
you drink spanish fly that was a hot
thing when i was a kid spanish fly to
get you horny
so i'm like maybe if i drink like a
gallon of it
like you had to eat all these capsules i
just can't then i gave and then it
didn't work
that's [__] up when you think a sex
drug helps and you eat them it don't get
you wanted so i tried them with my
grandmother
like one day right she was home after
bingo and i said graham
i put him like another iced tea you
people are looking at me like you're
[__] crazy i did because
you need a guinea pig for these horny
pills to see you know i figured she's
like 80 if she gets horny these
[__] work and i'm saying
if in an hour grandma's scratching up
against the wall like a cat
i'm giving these to everybody tomorrow
everybody's getting these
the school lunch lady everybody's got me
i'm [__] everybody you understand me
this is my big break right here
then comes that day like you're in the
bathroom like this is a day i'm gonna
[__] bang one on it's gonna happen
and it's the weirdest thing because
you're banging it out and also like you
you start getting lightheaded
and you hear the voice but it's not
coming out of your mouth no more it's
just in your head now
it's like
and you're [__] banging it and all of
a sudden you're ready to
listen your mother bangs hurry up the
bus is waiting for you out there you're
like i'll be right out there mom
[__] busy and you're [__] going
for it i'm lefty when i whack off i'm
ready during the day but i don't know
why how i picked that habit up
and when you come for the first time
remember guys what happens to you just
black the [__] out
like you just black out the room spins
real [__] fast
you think you're like a diabetic i got
to go for a doctor's shot on monday
i'll never eat a lollipop again you know
what i'm saying
and you wake up you're on the floor
you're bleeding from your [__] eyelid
because
you hit it against the toilet thing that
holds the [__] paper
and you're like what happened oh my god
i'm sick i'll never jerk off again
in the middle of all you're like i came
that's what happened and you're looking
for it you go on like a [__]
scavenger hunt
and you find something on the back of
your hand like just
and the first one has weird stuff on it
looks like an egg yolk like it has
it's got like egg shells on it and [__]
you look at it you're like what the [__]
is this i came and you
you hear like yeah he's like a russell
apart you see like a picture of russell
crowe and she like i'm there i've
arrived
i'm here to free my people and [__]
but you got this [__] on your hand you're
like what am i gonna do with it
[__] it i'll take it to school
that's what i did the chicks like don't
eat it what the [__] is wrong with you
you're a nasty [__] you're my
type of girl you know what i'm saying
[Applause]
she [__] eats it that one she don't
even drink it she's like [__]
freezes it takes it out later
what are you eating i had a piece of
bread i put some leftover sperm on
you don't eat it but you sniff it as a
guy remember the first time you came how
you
come on guys don't lie you're snifty
like oh my god it smells like chlorine
and [__]
you even gave it like a little taste and
[__]
it's not that bad
not a glob not like fish chick
but just a little taste
[__] disgusting the stuff we do as
kids
see ladies now you understand the
evolution
now you know why we're so [__] up
about it we don't even know why like
what's the big deal about you drinking
it i don't know
we just don't want it to go to waste you
know what i'm saying for years i wasted
it on [__] in my house you know what i'm
saying
i'm a man now i want something done with
this [__]
some chick like